all right this is for shaycarl who I
think was my friend and he called me out
on this
and of course been Lidl he's the CEO
over at Healthways also and a bunch of
you other people out there called me
into this as well now I want to
introduce the other people taking this
with me our Ramsey personalities Rachael
Cruz Christie right and Chris Brown are
also taking it with us my family's up
here my son Daniel my wife Sharon are
going to do the dump on me Suzanne is a
team member is going to take care of
Christie and my daughter Denise
Whittemore Rachel's husband Winston are
going to take care of Rachel now Ramsey
family foundation is going to donate
$7,500 to ALS and our team has also
raised $7,500 so $15,000 going and we're
not going we're gonna put on the check
no embryonic stem cell research for
those checks now this is dedicated for
George Fletcher who is Kelly Daniels dad
Kelly Daniels dad she's our Associate
Producer passed away of ALS Andy
Plunkett who is Damien's dad one of our
IT guys he passed away from ALS as well
we've got a local firefighter here in
the area named Doug Goddard who is
retired because of ALS and I lost my
cousin's husband and um Adam Stein to
ALS as well I'm gonna go and do my
challenge cuz I don't know if I'm gonna
breathe after this in a minute we were
gonna do Brad Paisley my buddy there
because he likes water but he's already
had his or michael w smith my buddy cuz
hey friends are friends right but he's
already done his and but I think what
we're gonna do is I'm gonna throw out a
challenge to Mark Cuban cuz he got
plenty of money and John Rich cuz he
always says hey don't threaten me with a
good time so I'm gonna throw up throw
out the challenge to those two guys and
that that's our deal all right
here we go alright buckets ready folks
here we go three two one oh my gosh oh
wait a minute it's not over the whole
company's in we're challenging
so cheer ladies Churchill mortgage and
life starts to do TV Craig Groeschel we
challenge you we challenge Mike Hardwick
[Music]
[Applause]
400 people man 400 people thank you the
Brentwood Fire Department one more time
we challenged Craig Groeschel god I'm so
cold
Rochelle and the team the ministry team
at Life Church Stevie and Mike Hardwick
and the team at Churchill mortgage your
whole team baby